hello went welcome to this video playing
bulton and I am Bolton okay yes
mentioned in the earlier video this
isn't particularly great c 5 but we'll
see what happens I had exactly the same
again another in a in an earlier game
and it was pretty terrible for black I
really wonder why people play into that
ok so how to do that now queen d 5 is a
move I'm not sure this great though p 8
but should be too
and am I not just winning material there
also if I play Bishop f4 they know is
that it's really weird I know but isn't
this good here but shouldn't be seven
queen bee three I mean Bishop e7 doesn't
seem to be working and if you place
route kicks [ __ ] who I play Bishop b5
maybe Nyjah have six very weird stuff
but interesting yeah here i also have
queen aid Queen aid what then will see 5
Wow oh em
Queen 88 Roxy five hmm that's really not
to take that I'm a hard time believing
that
maybe just be should be three actually
okay I have no time you I mean I'm sorry
and no x wrong I have time on the clock
but I don't have time to figure it out
okay now he does that okay okay that's
not the perfect outcome here definitely
not yeah I hello this is the kind of
thing that you afterwards give to the
computer and would have liked to fret
them but I didn't see it very likely I
can take on b2 now I guess not sure that
says that there is a clear argument
against it his rook has very little
squares but then k just a text here if I
go for development okay I just have to
go along with instincts here and play
rugby to Luke p1 is Bishop they only
seven
I thought ish he has to check on be 20
is that really not working oh this one
and don't expect any more here that's
probably what what happens if you play
into such a wacky line I'm just trying
for a 3 now trapping the rook formally
will take the exchange or sacrifice some
exchange there on d4 bit or maybe a some
tactic with 94 that's possible possible
it even if he sacrifices the exchange
there with Ruta for isn't it isn't
totally easy to play
I was taking a huge timeout them now you
will sacrifice definitely be three Reds
as it is it some kind of compensation
absolutely I III rooted for I don't see
how to avoid it I wonder really if I
should it's not so clear what is doing
there besides sacrificing anyway if I
just centralized I have Bishop F 695
this kind of idea in some cases so I
just centralized what what is he doing
is to sacrifice anyway I was thinking
that much and now yeah what to do yeah
before is hanging c3 is hanging let's go
back here
95 the i will take c 2 at the end it's
not exactly great not sure how to
organize this Queen you three looks bad
yeah 94 maybe even okay it's not so easy
to okay now I know it's easy I'm happy
to centralize without taking with the
porn i mean time warning
maybe it couldn't be 7 immediately was
possible okay I still have this option
and a queen is somewhat disturbing for
black
now should be good for me
why it's also still the exchange I mean
shouldn't completely disregard the
material here okay that hangs I don't
want to retreat here I'm probably after
Oh whoopsie seven check don't have many
squares there it's got a draw wow I can
take em okay that took me a long time to
see and it took time it took time on the
clock yeah let's see if I can open up
now here check will be seven
unfortunately
nice little temple move and I'm
promoting now check check check check
check check mate okay that was close at
the end okay yeah I'd really like to
know what is opening it looks like it
really looks like there should be
something so I have everything this is
close to unplayable this stuff like has
no development and okay nighty five wins
yeah I looked at this move button I
wasn't quite sure if this is so great
yeah but what is he doing here look
before has to play this stuff and then
this and yeah like resins basically okay
and i was i was actually not respecting
would be five Bishop b5 strong okay well
okay i didn't didn't see that one
and hey it's pretty Nita why does a
piece up okay and this isn't clear at
all it seems we should be too was
something that he can play and then a
four I was thinking this but wow so it's
a complete mess computer likes white but
I mean that's why this bad i developed
so but makes it I understand why white
could be better but it's it's also
complete a complete mess ok and here i
went there yeah III he will take anyway
so b3 and her group t1 letting him take
their ID six or something that the
engine likes of course here days this is
probably a little bit yeah this now is a
c3 hanging guy it's a complete mess the
way it went eih three and now he is
surprised me with this I thought I felt
that was very useful for me that I get
in 95 I had thought about the move here
already but but I wasn't sure about this
didn't see any of any great move here
okay the comp gives this but ok come in
comparison i like this more I mean get
to give black some some rope and I
should go queen bee 7 immediately i saw
that idea far to lay this is winning
flat out it's the double attack I saw
that saw that too late I mean it still
wins i guess but check more complicated
I just wanted to simplify this is not
the
probably will be seven to rub it in a
little bit does it even do that much but
ok I think it it served its purpose
white will promote now like this this
question is when winning this for
example no idea this is a draw could be
a draw this is again one of those
positions where the computer is totally
useless it gives + 3 + well everybody
sees that white is a queen up but how
exactly are you winning the game
I don't see away actually that looks
black puts the look on d5 let's say and
shuffles with the king could be wrong
could be a draw okay now all a tough
game thanks for watching